I should really spend this movie into
sounding cooler than it actually is like
this movie stars pac-man centipede and
Donkey Kong are here to destroy the
world in reality it's an Adam Sandler
movie
do not be fooled pixels so pixel stars
Adam Sandler Kevin James Josh GAD Peter
Dinklage and Michelle Monaghan and in
1982 we sent a probe up into space to
search for intelligent life to show them
our pop culture unfortunately we
included video games in that I supposed
to be don't know what you're looking at
centipede space invaders Donkey Kong it
does look pretty hostile but the aliens
took it as a declaration of war now they
have created video games in real life to
attack her video games that my audience
are probably not going to know what they
are ask your parents in fact ask your
dad he'll know or your uncle Jeff who no
one invites to the get-togethers he'll
definitely know and so now the Nerds of
yesteryear the only hope for the human
race now I'm gonna be honest with you
guys this isn't as bad as Adam Sandler
movies have been lately in fact there is
actually enjoyment in the movie when the
video game is going down it's
actually pretty clever like pac-man is
tromping through New York so they get in
there different colored cars which are
the colors of the ghost and pac-man but
they have to beat these video game
scenarios per the rules of the game it
was really neat seeing pac-man be played
out in real life I was like a Superbowl
commercial that you thought was the best
Superbowl commercial in the Super Bowl
this year like that but you know streets
of New York when the video game stuff is
going down in this movie you're having
fun but really everything that happens
in between the times where the video
game aliens are kicking our ass it's
cheese it's nonsense and it's kind of
awkward and part first of all Adam
Sandler Michelle Monaghan Michelle
Monaghan is in this movie simply to be a
love interest for Adam Sandler yeah
you're calling I'm calling
you call from the very
beginning from the get-go Adam Sandler's
like installing electronics at her home
and then from there it's just you're not
buying any of it you're like if for
nothing else this has the creep vibe
going down anyone tried to pull the
Adam Sandler was pulling in this scene
you'd 911 and the jokes were kind of
awkward at a point I forgot this was a
comedy I was actually enjoying the video
game that I forgot oh yeah first
and foremost this is a comedy I should
be laughing didn't really laugh in this
movie in fact I was like why is the
voice of Olaf humping the stage when
he's singing at the party Peter Dinklage
does his best in this movie Kevin James
was the most likable character
hands-down believable no but likable the
last
activist movies pretty fun I had a
really good time an Adam Sandler I mean
he's blamed life-size Donkey Kong he's
taking the hammer and he just slamming
those barrels your luck I enjoy seeing
that that's because I used to play that
on the Atari and it's just neat
seeing it on the screen ask your parents
what that is honestly guys pixels has
got to be one of the movies it's just
the most wasted potential of the year
the premise is genius it's great video
games coming to wipe us out and the
reason they give is believable enough
for a movie like this a comedy after all
it's easy to pitch in a movie that we
sent a probe into space alien sawed took
it as hostile and sent life-sized video
games back to kill us sounds ridiculous
when I'm saying it but in the movie it
would be viable from there you can have
a pretty good time this movie doesn't
actually transcend into good time this
movie at best hits wasted potential
which video game shit's really fun to
watch but in the end you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus one day ya
already forgot you might crack out that
old Commodore 64 your parents ask him
alright guys so pixels have you seen it
why are you gonna see it what did you
think about it or strike that what's
your favorite old video game of all time
if you say call of duty I swear to God
just don't do that whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more